27 دقيقه المده المسموح بها لتعبر هذه
الاجواء شمال تايوان ذهابا وايابا قرار
فرضته السلطات الصينيه في احدث اجراء فيما
يتعلق بالجزيره التي تريد بكين ضمها
وزاره النقل التايوانيه قالت ستخفض مده
حظر طيران التي ستفرضها فوق شمال تايوان
من سبع ساعات الى سبع وعشرين دقيقه فقط في
الخطه الاوليه ولمده ثلاثه ايام ابتداء من
السادس عشر من ابريل وحتى الثامنه عشر من
الشهر نفسه حيث سيؤثر الامر على 60 الى
70% من الرحلات بين شمال شرق اسيا وجنوب
شرق اسيا وزاره الدفاع التايوانيه قالت ان
الحظر مفرود من جانب الصين وليس تايوان
وان منطقه حظر الطيران تقع في حدود منطقه
التعريف الدفاع الجوي للتايوان رجحت
الوزاره ان حظر الطيران يتعلق بشكل اساسي
بنشاطات فضائيه صينيه او اطلاق قمر
اصطناعي
كانت اجرت خلال الايام القليله الماضيه
مناورات عسكريه ودفعت ببعض طائراتها
وقطاعها البحريه العسكريه الى ما بعد الخط
الذي يفصل مضيق التايوان منصفه بين
البلدين ويشكل خط المواجهه بينهما في
سيناريو لفرض حصار على الجزيره وحظر جوي
وبحري كان التقارير استخباراتيه توقعت ان
تلجا الصين الى الحصار بدلا من الغزو
المباشر حصار يبدو ان بيكين بداته بسبع
وعشرين دقيقه في خطتها الاوليه كما سمتها
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات